can you take me through that story of
the apartment bombings and how you
covered that story yeah okay well that's
the most important I mean if you want to
understand Russia then you have to
understand the apartment bomb the story
of the apartment bombings and this is
when Putin was well Putin was at first
the head of the FSB which is the
successor organization to the KGB but
um during the 1990s when Russia was
transformed
from a socialist country
with us all property in the hands of the
state to a kind of capitalist society in
which in under any circumstances
property was in private hands
the
um
the consequences for the Russian people
were just horrific this is when all the
oligarchs took out like well they were
created but but the the the the
and they were created because the
property of the Soviet Union the
resource companies the the ports the
facilities they were all carved up among
corrupt insiders who became oligarchs
became known as oligarchs they didn't
create anything they were not true
businessmen they were people who
benefited from the corruption in order
to steal what it or what already existed
but the consequences of this this type
of privatization
were disastrous for the Russian economy
which collapsed I mean the the the
national income fell by by 50 percent
well that didn't happen even under Nazi
occupation
and uh
the the
population for the most part with the
exception of a very small group
was thrown into grinding poverty
and it created a a profound
psychological crisis which led to among
other things a very high
death rate
in the Years
1990 of 19 in the 1990s
when Russia's was being transformed
economically
the uh the death rate in Russia reached
the level
of
it reached unprecedented levels for an
industrial country in fact during that
period according to demographers there
were six million excess Surplus deaths
now Surplus deaths or Surplus mortality
is a term that's used by demographers
uh
to describe deaths that could not have
been anticipated on the basis of
previously existing Trends this is what
demographers do they look at for example
if they want they now it's 2022 they
want to say you know what is the
population going to be in 2030 for
example in a given country well they
look at all of the relevant Trends you
know the the the the the the the way the
economy is going the the climate the uh
you know investment uh the pro you know
the health situation the Improvement in
medicine and so on and so forth it
advances or or or or or problems in the
area of child mortality and then they
make on the on the basis of a of a
reasonable projection they say well the
population is going to be X you know you
know certainly well people did that for
Russia of course during the 1990s and
especially uh targeted the year 2000
which was a logical Target
and the the difference between what they
predicted and what uh what in in fact
occurred was six million extra deaths
uh suicide rate doubled
accident rate went way up uh people died
in in unprecedented
unprecedented numbers
cardiological from our cardiovascular
disease cancer
uh the murder rate
uh you know became arguably the highest
in the world uh all of these things
contributed and uh
there was also just a profound
psychological crisis for many people who
had who trained uh to believe in one
system were thrown into another system
uh for which they were very poorly
prepared in any case uh
Yeltsin was the president
his policies contributed to this
situation
not only contributed to it they were
they were instrumental and the result
was that his popularity in Russia was
practically zero
public opinion polls showed that he had
two percent approval in the country when
Putin
was promoted to the role of prime
minister from head of the FSB his
popularity rating in the only poll that
was taken before the bombings
was two percent it was generally
considered to be out of the question
that Yeltsin or anyone appointed by
Yeltsin could possibly succeed Yeltsin
as president and in 2000 he there were
new elections and the Constitution said
he could only serve two terms
[Music]
it was at that point
that the buildings in Moscow began and
in Russia began to be blown up in the
middle of the night killing you know
hundreds of people
uh those bombings were attributed
uh by the Russian authorities to the
chechens who had after the a war in the
early 1990s created a kind of uh
independent state which was not widely
recognized but you know it had autonomy
from Russia and uh that was the basis
for launching a new war against chechnya
and Putin was put in charge of it
suddenly Putin this completely
uncharismatic person who no one had ever
heard of in fact who had never had a
career as a public politician
uh was everywhere vowing bloody Revenge
against the uh
the terrorists who had murdered innocent
Russian people in their beds and the the
second Chechen War achieved early
successes they were well prepared for it
they used banned weapons uh cluster
bombs uh thermobaric weapons uh and
they bomb markets as you know as they
have a tendency to do
and they bombed civilian areas just as
they're doing now in Ukraine and the six
the initial success
of the government
uh under Putin in pursuing that war
um raised Putin's popularity and he
overnight became the leading com leading
Contender for the presidency and in fact
was elected president and his first
official Act was to Pardon Yeltsin and
yeltsin's corrupt family for all crimes
committed while they were while they
were in office
so those bombings were very convenient
and there was a lot of circumstantial
evidence that pointed to not chechens
but the the the Russian intelligence
Services the real authors of those
of those explosions
but what clinched the argument
was a fifth bomb
that didn't go off
that was placed in the basement of an
apartment building in the city of riazon
which is southeast of Moscow
what happened was uh you know the whole
country was
was petrified
uh with fear
no one knew what apartment building
would be blown up next
and at that moment uh this bomb was
was placed in the basement of the
building in riazon but people were were
on the lookout and and the the bombers
were were noticed and the police were
called
and uh the perpetrators the people who
had put the bomb in the build the bomb
was defused the people who had put the
bomb in the basement were caught
and they turned out to be FSB agents not
church and terrorists they produced FSB
identification really yeah
and the bomb was a live bomb it was made
uh cons out of the same material hexagon
which is used to top off artillery
shells it's high explosive that was used
in the the previous bombings
and uh
the the the FSB hastily
announced that this was
uh not an attempt to blow up a building
this was a training exercise
well you know believe that and
I mean for one thing he couldn't have
been a training exercise because under
the law if there's a training exercise
all of the officials in the locality
were the exercises being
conducted have to be informed none of
them knew it was a training exercise the
bombers used a stolen car well they
wouldn't have needed a stolen car if it
had been a legitimate exercise and in
fact uh the the bomb itself tested
positive for hexagon which is a very
dangerous explosive and the Detonator
which was filmed in time stamped
uh uh was a live military Detonator and
you can't carry out an exercise with a
live bomb in a civilian apartment
building so that was you know but and
then people who began to investigate
they were all killed
uh journalists
um
uh deputies in the parliament the Lower
State Duma which is the Russian
Parliament
and uh
Alexander lifanenko a former uh FSB
agent who wrote about this was poisoned
with a radioactive isotope in London you
may remember that case it was put in his
tea and then he just was kind of
consumed from within by radiation uh
so there's really no doubt
that that's how Putin came to power what
else did they have to gain
by creating a new war with chechnya's
sides gaining that political approval
for him to gain power well that was the
that was the main thing that was primary
it was to yeah and and of course you
know there was a nationalist motive of
course because the chechens had
humiliated Russia by defeating them in
the first church in war and you know for
given Russia's
national pride and and and so on I mean
they may they may have wanted to to blot
out that disgrace as they understood it
but the point is what it really what did
was it put it it um
uh
uh it elevated Putin